hey guys pete here today i'm going to do
a breakdown of fargo season 4
episode 4 the pretend war it gets a
little creepy
there's some dread lurking around in the
background we learn more about orienta's
modus operandi
as the two criminal factions try to sort
out what's really going on and how to
make the right moves to hold on to their
power
a real quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 4 yet then this
video won't be for you
hit subscribe go get caught up and then
come back to watch this recap and review
now let's get started i mentioned in my
video for the last episode that i was
picking up some supernatural vibes from
swanny's talk of the devil
and a possible family curse this week
after a creepy intro
that takes a look around the king of
tears mortuary after hours
we visit etherida in her room she hears
something that prompts her to take a
look outside her door
and when she looks she sees a ghost like
man i don't know that's the best way to
describe it
something unworldly sitting on the
staircase
we don't get any more information here
but we do see another ghost encounter
when zelmer is washing the money in the
tub
so i'll come back to this at the end of
the video in an over the top scene the
cannons trap a fodder truck
inside a ring of fire i'm not sure how
possible something like this is but have
to say
it looked pretty menacing they end up
burning the driver
but only bran the cheek of constant
kalamata with the barrel of a gun to
send a message
again i'm not sure about the whole ring
of fire but i did find it funny that
after they took the truck they just
drove it through the fire to leave
this prompts another sit-down meeting
between abel and dr
senator things are flipped this time
with the italian taking care of the
monologuing he shares his immigrant
experience and how he didn't understand
the phrase american values that he kept
hearing
after he arrived over time he decided
that to be an american
is to pretend adopt the attitude that
you have a right to be here and that
you've always had a right to be here
he can accept that but can't pretend
that the two factions are at peace when
they're actually at war
here's the thing though he's there about
the truck robbery but doesn't know it
was done in retaliation
the cannons are reacting to the spring
street stick up that zelmer and swanny
pulled off
and the failed hit on loy's oldest son
lemuel abal is unprepared since he
doesn't know that gaetano is making
moves behind josto's back
and to this point no one knows what's
going on with the fugitives
in their conversation doctor makes it
plain it seems to me you ain't tracked
in on
all the critical goings-ons in your
house these days
across town it appears that josto
learned orienta's name and where she
lived because they're going at it with a
little erotic asphyxiation thrown in for
good measure
this seems to have heightened the
pleasure this time around but i can't
help wondering if this
is the kind of thing you would want to
get into with this kind of character
their post-coital conversation gives us
some insights into orienta's inner world
she loves the idea of going to istanbul
and really doesn't like cursing
saying sleep with a mouthful of razors
it's your own throat that gets cut
he explains that he won't be traveling
to istanbul anytime soon
after all he needs to stay in town and
watch over his family
he's in charge although he would like
some more fluffy whiz-bang if she's got
it and he confesses he wants to kill dr
harvard or he had a claim she's an enemy
to no man but come on we know that's not
true
as he's leaving etheridal shows up at
the door to ask if she can
take orienta up on her offer of a house
cleaning job orienta tries to brush her
off because she's on her way to work but
etherida is able to persuade her
things go well until she does the one
thing she wasn't supposed to do
she looks inside the hall closet where
she finds a stockpile of drugs
a box full of obituaries that are all
clipped out
and all sorts of personal effects like
medals
glasses and jewelry it might take the
smutny girl a minute to put things
together but as viewers we know what
we're looking at
orienta apparently keeps trophies from
all her kills
and from the looks of things there's a
lot of them considering that ethel ryda
left her notebook behind
and took what was probably the worst
trophy that she could have chose
donna telefada's ring it shouldn't be
long until orienta knows that she knows
about her secret
when josto was leaving he ran into rabbi
milligan and found out that gaetano
had ordered him to kill lemuel cannon
this has him head straight over to
confront his younger brother
firing several shots in the office
before getting him to back down
by training the gun on his brother's
private parts it's an effective display
of
power for the time being but it's hard
to imagine it's the end of the matter
after talking with dr senator about his
conversation with
zafada concieri and deciding that the
robbery at spring street was just some
crime
lloyd goes looking for a rabbi himself
maybe it's because they talked before or
more likely
it's because he thinks he can use the
fact that the fadas aren't his blood to
his advantage
there's no way that rabbi can help him
get satchel back it's just not possible
so after cutting his hand loy makes
himself clear
anything happens to my boy either of my
boys
it's going to be like you killed them so
rabbi is the one guy who actually
is taking care of satchel but he's also
on the hook if the
fada family does anything that hurts him
or his brother
at the kansas city police department we
watch as otis
fails in an attempt to get rid of
marshall deffy he has an informant come
in and do a terrible job of saying
that he overheard zelmer and swanee were
on their way to chicago
and duffy isn't swayed he explains that
he works at a federal agency which means
that he can just make a phone call to
their office in chicago and let them
know he
tells them kansas city was my mandate
and kansas city is where i'll stay
otis then has no choice but to let him
come along to the father headquarters
where he tells them he's going to speak
with a different informant
while the marshal is waiting in the car
gaitano's angry pacing out front catches
his interest
he approaches the gangster and while
snacking on some carrots tells him a
story about some italians that tried to
come to salt lake city
he says they tried to make our sons
junkies and our daughters [ __ ]
they were dissuaded of that notion with
a noose and some horses
adding that they must have dragged them
six or seven miles before their heads
popped off
while this kind of talk might intimidate
your average citizen i think it probably
comes off more like a challenge to
constant and gaitano
seems like this won't be the last time
we see these three face off
things wrap up with zelmer delivering a
bag of cash to her brother-in-law from
the robbery
she did her best to clean the puke off
it at the hotel as swanny is in bed
recovering from eating the pie
their meeting is a nice moment between
these two characters that certainly
feels like it's setting up
something less pleasant zelmaire may be
a criminal but we get a chance to see
that she
cares about her sister and her family
unfortunately she robbed lloyd cannon to
pay their debt
to loy cannon her unsuspecting
brother-in-law head straight over to the
house to drop off the bag of cash
he's met with the barrel of a shotgun at
the front door which ensures he's afraid
and
uneasy throughout the conversation he's
basically squirming the whole time
the whole thing is suspicious and after
thurman leaves lloyd gets a whiff of the
puke and knows this is some of the money
that was stolen from him
with the crushing debt lifted from his
shoulders thurman comes home to
celebrate
the feeling doesn't last because dubrel
figures out right away how this all came
to be
she knows that her sister's involvement
means that this could all
lead to a disaster worse than being in
debt for the family the episode ends as
her dad tells ethel ryda that things
will be alright
it'll all blow over soon enough but we
can tell he's having a hard time
convincing
himself that's the case just as he says
it i think this was on par with the last
episode i mean overall it felt more like
setup than anything else
it all seemed necessary if not entirely
satisfying but i like the tension in a
lot of these scenes and that feeling of
dread
sneaking in there it all worked well
things are moving around putting
themselves in place
and a hot war is just barely being held
off by the power struggle on the fada
side
and the caution on the cannon side at
the same time
everything else is conspiring to make
sure the violence escalates
and now there are ghosts as well last
week i mentioned that the hints of the
supernatural
inside the king of tears made me wonder
if the man in the street at the end of
episode 1 was connect
i think we could say yes to that after
seeing the figure on the stairs
we didn't get a great look at the one in
the hotel or the one in the street but
if they're not the same exact ghost or
whatever we want to call it then they're
definitely connected
abel showed us that he can give as good
as he gets and his monologue was right
up there with dr
senators from last week i guess he'll be
going on a trip to kiss the ring in new
york which may
turn out to help in getting their house
in order he seems like the most reliable
of josto's men
so his being away might also lead to
more stress
in their sorting out who's in charge the
ape or the pipsqueak
ethel ryda and her parents continue to
be the most sympathetic characters
but zelmer was elevated up to the same
level as her partner this week
putting them right there in that same
category together this bunch also seems
to be the people who are most at
risk and i don't see that getting any
better rabbi continues to be one of the
most interesting gangsters
and now he's in a tough position from
all sides he's got a threat in his own
house with gaetano
and now lloyd cannon has his eyes on him
as well deffy
and orienta continue to be the most fun
to watch
the if a man's pud needed a tug would
this be the place for said tugging line
was one of the best from this
episode and it will be interesting to
see what orienta's next move is
i imagine her attention will focus
itself on ethel ryder now that she knows
her secret but josto did bring up the
idea of wanting her boss dr harvard dead
and you know she has a disposition where
she likes to kill people
the only direct callback that jumped out
at me was the mention of mort kellerman
we heard loy say that he wanted to send
him some of the guns in fargo
this is a character that showed up in a
flashback in season 2
in the fargo underworld where he was
killed off by the gerharts
with that i'll leave it there let me
know what you think in the comments
where do you think this season is
heading and what are you hoping to see
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you